a few days ago i hope you celebrated
because our country celebrated
a trans day of visibility is what it's
called
the trans day of visibility this was
supposed to be a time to focus on trans
people celebrate trans people
talk about the bravery and beauty of
trans people in other words it was a day
just like
every other day our experience with the
trans day of visibility
is like bill murray's experience with
groundhog's day it repeats forever
nothing changes it never ends indeed
there's there's never been
a group as fractionally tiny as the
trans population and yet so visible
there there's never been a community so
small and yet so accommodated
by society for the sake of trans people
we've
changed the english language thrown out
the rules of grammar
past laws effectively abolished women's
sports tossed biological science into
the wood chipper come to think of it
there has never been a population of any
size majority or minority
that's been given those sorts of
considerations most of all
we've never seen such a concerted and
effective effort
to purposefully increase the size of a
particular population
there are 10 times as many
trans-identifying people in generation z
as there are in older generations and
that figure is no accident
it's also not the organic result of
people simply feeling more
free to live in their authentic
identities live their truths
now that society is allegedly more open
and tolerant than it was in the past no
this is rather the result of programming
children are
initiated into the left's gender theory
religion
and one twitter thread meant to
commemorate our trans
day of visibility perfectly demonstrates
how this works
so it's worth looking at the thread from
a podcaster named jesse thorne
has been liked and retweeted thousands
of times by leftists who insist that
it's heartfelt
beautiful of course stunning
in it jesse explains how he and his wife
who hosts her own podcast by the way
appropriately titled one bad mother
those are her words that's her podcast
title not mine
but he explains how they first
discovered that their son was a girl
the left tells us that this is a perfect
explanation of the trans phenomenon
among kids and i completely agree
actually
so here's the story as he tells it okay
he says quote i'm the parent of a trans
kid i want to clarify what that means as
best i can
because a lot of folks don't know or
make incorrect presumptions
happy hashtag trans day of visibility
my daughter is nine when she was born we
assumed she was a boy
gave her a boy name called her he we
gave her all kinds of toys she generally
preferred the ones our culture
associates with boys
like building toys trucks and robots she
hated getting haircuts
and always wanted her hair long like my
wife's but we just figured kids hate
haircuts
she loved the jungle book especially the
part where baloo the bear dresses up in
a hula skirt
but what kid doesn't love that when she
started kindergarten my wife was bathing
her
hopefully it's not the first time the
child was bathed but uh we'll we'll get
past that
an adult friend of ours had just come
out as trans and my wife mentioned
that not all girls have vaginas and not
all boys have penises
our daughter asked some girls have
penises my wife said yes
whether you're a boy or girl wasn't
about your private parts
i'm a girl with a penis my daughter said
all of a sudden
all these things that had confused us
about her when she was younger made
sense
we went to learn about gender and kids i
mean i'm from san francisco grew up with
a trans neighbor
my wife went to sarah lawrence we were
open but pretty ignorant
well on that last point i must agree
as for the rest uh i i still am not
ready to accept
that so many people can read all of that
what i just read to you and come away
thinking
yes well clearly that child was really a
girl all along
this proves it it is possible that half
of the country
has literally gone insane but i think
it's more likely that lots of people
pretend
for political and social reasons to
accept and agree with what they know
is irrational and indefensible that's
one of the things that makes this
subject so frustrating
is that when you're arguing with people
it's a very good chance that the person
you're arguing with
knows that you're right but won't admit
it
let's review the process by which jesse
and his wife teresa came to the
conclusion that their little boy
had a little girl trapped inside him he
said this this is this is the story that
he tells
it's not me being reductive or anything
like that this is his story
he says that his son enjoyed playing
with trucks and robots
so far so normal he also hated getting
his hair cut
in my experience with my two sons this
is also quite normal
i've never known a young boy who likes
getting his hair i didn't like getting
haircut when i was a young boy
i don't think any boys like getting
their haircuts
the boy enjoyed the film the jungle book
again my own sons can relate i like the
jungle book too when i was a kid
but he was especially fascinated with
the scene where baloo the bear wears a
hula skirt and dances around well
what child isn't fascinated with a
dancing bear and a hula skirt
now even if it were possible for a male
child to
in some sense be a girl which it's not
how could any of this be sufficient
evidence to support that conclusion
this doesn't pass the smell test even if
we accept
the fantastically delusional premise
that boys can theoretically be girls and
vice versa
in no universe this universe or the
fantasy land that the left pretends we
inhabit
is this boy's behavior indicative of
anything other than
a normal boy who has normal boy-like
interests
yes the boy said that he's a girl with a
penis
but he only said that after his mother
told him
that some girls have penises if you tell
a five-year-old boy that some dragons
are three and a half feet tall
and look a lot like five-year-old boys
he's almost certain to inform you that
he is just such a dragon
what a coincidence kids are highly
suggestible
they have underdeveloped brains they
have an underdeveloped sense of the
world in reality
they can't distinguish between fact and
fiction a child at five
can't be meaningfully accused of telling
a lie because he doesn't fully
understand the difference between a lie
and the truth you know recently i came
into the kitchen and i found a broken
glass on the floor um and uh
and and i asked my four-year-old who was
closest by
if he broke it and over the course of
the brief interrogation
he told me that he did break it but he
didn't break it
but it was already broken that his
brother broke it and that the dog broke
it
we don't have a dog he he doesn't have
enough of a grasp on reality to deceive
me effectively because he's just a small
child
and everything that he says every claim
that he makes
should be understood in that context
jesse doesn't have a grasp on this basic
fact of child psychology or has chosen
to ignore it
now he goes on through the lengthy
thread to describe
how his son socially transitioned quote
unquote in kindergarten
now at the age of nine jesse is thinking
about what sorts of drugs he wants to
put the child on
he also goes into detail about the
herculean efforts needed to protect his
boy's
parentally imposed delusions this is
what he writes
we still had to and have to be on guard
at all times
uh every nuke every new care situation
camp sports babysitter
friends parents had to get a briefing we
had to check every room for jerks
because being misgendered or forced to
explain yourself is traumatic for a
young child
we basically had to be the professional
trainers for every set of grown-ups that
entered our kids lives
it was and remains exhausting i can only
imagine what it's like for adult trans
and gender non-conforming people
now jesse doesn't stop to consider why
an allegedly authentic identity should
require so much
work to preserve if his son is a girl
why does every adult in his vicinity
need to be prepped
on the proper ways to address him and
act around him my daughter
real daughter actual girl doesn't need
me to give a speech to every person she
comes across i don't need
to explain to anyone that she's a girl i
don't need to make any effort
at all to maintain her in her girl
identity
that's because there's a difference
between my daughter and his
the difference is that my daughter is a
daughter
the rest of the threat is is a
disturbing as disturbing and deluded as
what we've already reviewed
but there was one brief moment
of clarity lucidity jessie wrote
quote anyway she told us her new name
grace actually she initially said greece
but we figured out what she meant not
the clearest enunciator back then
ah yes you figured out what quote
she meant that is indeed the job of a
child of a parent i should say
children say many things and often don't
know what the words that they're using
actually mean they make claims that
aren't true and that they don't know
aren't you they express desires that are
not really their desires
they say things all the time that begin
with i want and a parent has to say
no you don't really want that you think
you do but you don't
it's your job as a parent to use your
maturity and wisdom
to guide your child lead them not be led
by them
jesse heard his quote daughter say that
quote she
wanted to be called greece well jesse
knew that greece is a ridiculous name
surely
he can't actually want that name and
even if he does it's for his own good
that you guide him to a different name
because he doesn't understand the
significance of a name you can't you
can't look ahead into the future
and consider what it will be like to
actually live with that name that's why
we give our kids their name
and even parents who let their children
choose their names still don't really
let them choose them
i mean you'll notice that you very
rarely hear
about a trans child who chooses their
own name
and is now referred to as dragon ninja
or giant pirate or something like that
it's odd isn't it all these all these uh
all these young kids who choose their
own names quote unquote they always
end up with trendy sounding names
they never end up with the kind of name
that you would expect a five-year-old to
choose
well that's because even the parents who
let
kids choose their own name won't really
let their children choose
any name they want because
we can't let them do that because what
because because they don't understand
what it means to have a name
but if you won't let the child choose
any name they want
why would you let your children choose
whatever gender they want
why don't they as jesse said try to
figure out
what a boy really means when he says
he's a girl with a penis
why don't these parents apply their
superior wisdom and maturity
to that situation and offer their
children some much needed guidance
well because they see their children as
political statements and fashion
accessories
that's the truth they don't see their
kids as kids they don't see their kids
as human beings
jesse was quite excited to talk about
his trans daughter on his podcast
but he can't very well brag about a kid
named greece
no he needs his son to be a girl named
grace
that's much more palatable to him
jesse that is more useful to him
and this is all really about him isn't
it
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content